hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play anonymous
messages okay I'm a little late to this
one this wasn't suggested a while ago
and some of my fellow youtubers have
already played it but I play it anyway
some people say it's a slender clone but
I read a yeah whatever give her
everything a try try to go anything with
open eyes open you heard me open eyes
open
open your eyes everybody hate me oh I
don't know where are you alrighty then
well this is interesting that was an
interesting uh entrance into the game
it's like I fell from the sky but I'm
not where I fell because obviously this
is different hello is this fun should
have stopped what murdering everyone in
that town you'd never stop me okay I got
a heart rate monitor in the top right we
got one of six messages so whoopty-doo
since these are whoa what are you who
weirdo okay so since these are anonymous
messages I'm just gonna assume that
they're from people that I don't care
about or something uh-huh Yuri asked me
why did it I don't regret it on things
so don't worry about me
I'm just fine haha I know there's
something weird about you oh why why I
know what did i do what did I do wrong
why did the forest try to murder me why
what did I ever do to the forest and how
did it get me like instantaneously blue
you're talking about the gods head
nothing will stop the gods head it's
another one of those things I see you
I'm not gonna need you you're all traps
whoa what's that that a person I know
it's not okay I see you so the forest is
alive and trying to mirror me that's a
nice touch I mean obviously the
collection mechanic is kind of nowadays
in horror games it's kind of all in both
of the horror games just because it's a
very easy game mode to get things to get
tough to get people to move through an
area to do things but I wouldn't say
that it's like a direct slender clone
just cuz it's like not only friends I've
got the gods dead yeah okay I wouldn't
say there is a direct sonic on just
because it's in the woods and you're
trying to collect something this is
actually pretty interesting I mean I
kinda didn't expect the forest to start
murdering me that's always nice yep hey
don't call me a fool I'm a cool dude
what's a tree run run from the tree all
right they're gonna get me
oh come on how do I even get away from
those sons of [ __ ] how do I do this
how do I do
how am I supposed to be able to do this
as soon as I like one of the tree
activates I die instantaneously I can't
run I can't even sprint anyway so how
about that
okay so Sears has gravestones strewn
throughout these woods for no reason
ah one I almost ran right into it you
hear the ominous whew
long before you actually find it yes
yeah the gods head yeah I'm gonna get it
I'm gonna win oh I saw you you popped up
out of nowhere you you I saw you there
there they actually seem like they like
appear why why do they do that trying to
get me I won't get me I'm too smart this
time I'm Way too smart
no yeah whatever don't give me advice
about things I already did I can't help
it now I'm a crazy psychotic bastard
what do you want from me do you want
something from me not kill everyone that
doesn't seem quite right okay so I'm
doing good this is number four all I
gotta do is find two more apparently I
see I see I'm on the lookout for those
those weird trees there's one over there
I'm just waiting for one to pop in front
of me cuz they're want to do that okay
nothing so far doing God don't good just
beautiful Emma they have one didn't you
they one didn't me why did they a one
Dhin me I don't you judge okay don't
kill me bro
do I hear your wool wool wool wool I
hear you were your Oliver one right in
front of me I almost walked into it oh
damn it I've looped back to where I was
um did I miss something did I miss one
most likely yes aw crap I uh I know I
walked into it now don't kill they don't
care they don't Kelly oh god I I'm so
close to winning what you actually left
me alone huh oh crap no I'm dead I'm
dying I'm dying I'm gonna die oh my eye
my vision has gone red why I'm leaving
the force can I just stay on the
outskirts and not worry about dying from
the horrible monsters can I stop well my
heart Reed seems to be going a bit high
no okay
yeah something about I think I forget
what her rate means death there was
something about that
- so giddy giddy gumdrops hooray
I don't know where I'm going damn it
this always happens I find everything
except the last one then I'm stuck
wandering the woods forever until I die
I see you don't think I don't I've been
here before because I think I picked one
up here and I'm gonna die cuz my heart
just keep going up if I stop can I heart
rate go back down please can I breathe
in through the nose out through the
mouth I don't care if I just breathe in
through my mouth how you don't have time
dammit I'm gonna die cuz there's a
fountain I don't think it's on the
outskirts anyway I think it's on the
inside oh I'm so boned I'm so boned
I'm saban unless it's over here because
I don't think that I went over here to
find what I need to define come on come
on gimme some why is my heart rate still
going up this don't make no sense bro
don't make no sense maybe because I'm
bleeding out is that why I'm bleeding to
death
damnit can't find the last one must be
in the center of the damn woods Oh
unless I find something foon I'm just
gonna make a dive because I think it's
either 180 or 200 is when I die for no
reason my heart rates gonna until I die
yep I think I'm doomed
I think I'm doomed doomed forever to
wander these Boxton woods in the middle
of these mountains which totally makes
sense
god dammit okay yeah my heart rate is
down in the red zone and I will keel
over at any moment lovely lovely lovely
lovely lovely can I find something
please please anything maybe you looked
ok I didn't want to find that I didn't
want to find that yeah okay alright I'm
gonna give this one more try and then
I'm gonna get out of here so let's just
give this another series try and make
sure very much so that we do not what
I'm going to do is I'm going to
immediately go into the outskirts and
then wander around the moor
Remer serious I just sound a [ __ ]
you're everywhere this time okay I just
got to find the landmarks they're not at
every landmark but that layout of the
area is the same ergo it wouldn't be too
difficult to get my bearings correct
okay there's a gravestone
ah it's a [ __ ] I was right there right
there okay not here so there are various
landmarks but not every landmark has a
thingy nope not today not today buddy
stupid for us why is the forest want to
kill me what did I ever do to the forest
besides burn it all down
I killed Smokey the Bear in that drunk
minecraft episode is that what they
don't like what a fool I know I know I
am food I know
oh come on what did I do I miss seeing
there's nothing here anyway you sons of
[ __ ] leave me alone no you stupid
ballerina trees just dull Noble and
elegant until you man I didn't even what
what what did I do
I didn't even see there is none there
there was none there what are you doing
wooing at me
don't ruin me why isn't there one here
I've only found two yeah but oh just
kill me kill me kill me kill me 21 2001
this doesn't make any sense
sudden agony ding-dong damn sensei like
appear at random locations uh you've
made everyone hate you I don't care
about everyone hating me I care about
beating this stupid game damn it I'm
like seriously it's a deathtrap it's
it's a friggin death crap
they're everywhere I can't even see any
sparkles I just want to see some damn
sparkles there's some sparkles no not
gonna get me no don't woohoo at me I
don't want any of your woowoo
you take your woowoo and you get out of
here
I bet these are messages to myself
anyway cuz I'm psycho super crazy not
just regular crazy I'm super crazy
because most of these horror games you'd
have to be super crazy to be wandering
around in the woods
in the middle of nowhere is there
sparkly over there I don't think there's
a sparkly over there but there's a
sparkly over there okay do you see is
Berkeley everybody no you do not okay
let's go
where'd the other sparkly go damn you
sparkly get back here where'd you go
there you are I hear it but I don't see
it why is that a thing gave it away
yes yes you stupid anonymous messages
okay looking for the spark leis I see
those barclays well what is that oh
that's a gravestone over there okay
so far so nothing ah come on son of a
[ __ ] get away from me a man I don't
know why they trigger sometimes and
sometimes not
I've been closer than that to one and it
hasn't done anything to me oh just give
it a I go yeah yeah yeah should have
stopped that's what they told me in
Geneva Oh
I mean Nicaragua that's what they told
me in Nicaragua there was one by the
fountain wait a minute how did I loop
back to the fountain that's there's no
way there's no way there's no way I look
back to the fountain and it wasn't the
exact opposite of the fountain exact
opposite end well then where's the last
one if I made a loop already I should
have seen the other ones the hell what
the hell game all right I'm just diving
through the center of the woods trying
to find something on the opposite end
cuz I know I've missed something it's
just a matter of what where and when and
why no no thank you
what where when and why why why why why
the eternal burning question in all
these horror games why why why why I
don't know no no no no no
Oh No okay there's a boxes I was just at
the boxes I remember the boxes so is
there something over here there is
another fasces bar guys don't die bro
don't die no no you're not gonna get me
no no no no sparkling sparkling blue
blue blue blue yeah yeah no yes
I knew it yeah I knew that and that was
it okay part key that was it okay I
can't say that that was like the best
horror game I've ever played in my life
because it wasn't um there was a lot of
things wrong with it that I've already
pointed out during my commentary but I'm
not gonna say it was horrible it's not
horrible it was it was a fun experience
but kind of aggravating it up after a
while the mechanics of the trees were an
interesting take on monsters but at the
same time um they were they were
unpredictable which can be a plus in
horror games but they're also
inconsistent which was is a negative in
horror game so so long as something is
I'm not I'm not experienced enough to
talk about it I had to think about what
I was gonna say but it's not bad I give
it an MIT and a mu and play it for
yourself to find out see what you want
to do with that so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
ha
from pipeline white flag
hi
bye-bye
Oh
my vision royally mashup